لدينا أحد شرائط مايكل كوهين ،
وهو التسجيل السري للرئيس
ترامب في عام 2016 الذي قدمه كوهين ، حيث ناقش هو
والمرشح ترامب بعد ذلك
الترتيبات المتعلقة بالدفع
لزميلة بلاي بوي السابقة في بلاي بوي كارين ماكدوغال
التي تم دفعها من قبل طرف ثالث
ديفيد بيكر كرئيس لـ  The National
Inquirer حدث كل هذا في الأشهر التي
سبقت الانتخابات الآن ، هذا ليس
تسجيلًا عالي الجودة وسيكون
ذا صلة بتحليله ، لذا أولاً أريد
أن أشغل التسجيل
الكامل الذي لا يتعلق جميعًا بالدفع ، لذا
استمع إلى  نفسك
[موسيقى]
ربما بسبب هذا سيكون من الأفضل
إذا لم تذهب كما تعلم
ربما بسبب هذا لذلك الشخص الذي
تعرف ما أردنا التخلص
منه لأنه خطأ مع هذا في مثل
هذا الهراء على
ما أعتقد  أعتقد أن هذا يختفي سريعًا ،
أعتقد أن ما أعتقد أنه ربما يكون من الأفضل
القيام بشيء جونسون فقط هذه المرة ، نعم
في غضون أسبوعين ، أعتقد
أنه من الأفضل الآن أن تعرف حسنًا
عزيزي تأخذ  اعتني بنفسك ، شكرًا Pam ، نعم
، أنا فخور بك لفترة طويلة ، ما الجديد في
استطلاعي الرائع بالمناسبة ، رأيت استطلاعًا رائعًا
يحرز تقدمًا كبيرًا يا رفاق ،
يا القس سكوت ، أيها الخاسر يعرف السيد.
سكوت ، ما هو ، أوه ، لا شكرًا ، هل يمكننا
استخدامه بعد الآن ،
أوه نعم 100 لا ،
لقد شعرنا أنه يلعب ، لا أقصد أن
الحروق الجماعية ، هل يمكننا استخدام ما يكفي ، لا ، أنا آسف لأنك
تعلم أن الاتصال التدريبي الذي أجريته للتو
لدي فرصة هنا كابوس بالنسبة لك ،
لذلك حصلنا على خدمتنا من صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز ، لقد أخبرتك أن هذا سيتطلب منا
الكشف عن أوراق الطلاق مع إيفانا ،
فنحن نحارب ذلك لأن الكبسولات لن تكون
أبدًا أبدًا قط لم تكن قط.
لن يتمكنوا أبدًا من عدم
امتلاك أي غرض مشروع ، انظر إلى
امرأة لا تريد أن تخسر ، صحح
بعضها في إنجلترا ، نعم ، لقد نسيت كل شيء
لثلاثة أسابيع الآن ما عليك القيام به هو
تأخير التأثير  حتى بعد ذلك
لن يتم فتحه على الإطلاق ، ليس
هناك أي غرض
لإخبارك عن تشارلستون ، أحتاج إلى
فتح شركة لنقل كل
تلك المعلومات المتعلقة بصديقنا ديفيد الذي
تعرفه حتى أفعل ذلك بشكل صحيح
بعيدًا ، لقد ظهرت بالفعل على شاشة التلفزيون وقمت
للتو باقتحام Alan weiselberger a
حول كيفية إعداد الأمر برمته
بالتمويل ، نعم ، كل شيء
يحشو كل الأشياء لأنك هنا
لا تعرف أبدًا أين تلك الشركة التي لا
تعرف أبدًا ما هو جيد ، لقد فهمها بشكل صحيح ،
لذا فقد انتهيت من ذلك وتحدثت إلى آلان
حول هذا الموضوع عندما يحين وقت
التمويل الذي
سيستمع إلى ما سألتزم به في إجابتي ،
حسنًا لا لا لا لا ، ليس لدي أي قلق